um I know you went and visited the
Border we had a border patrol security
uh we had a gentleman on here who was
the head of the border patrol oh Chris
clam no this guy he had retired huh Roy
Villarreal okay he came on here this is
two years ago and he was talking about
one of the biggest issues that he was
noticing at the border this was in
Arizona that was his jurisdiction was
that
um they people were getting the the the
the legislative branches weren't working
well so like they would arrest people
but they weren't Prosecuting them so
they would get just the same people back
over and over again so it seemed like
such a goose chase
um well it's gotten a hundred times
worse now wow because now that people
are just I mean I was there
between two and four a.m in the morning
I watched 300 people just walk across
and then the border patrol brings them
to the airport and um you know they prod
they fingerprint them if they're
criminal then they go into a different
you know line but the rest of them are
brought to the Yuma Airport
even a um uh a ticket to any place they
want to go on the United States and then
we pay for it if they don't have the
money for it and you know they've 110
000 planted in New York and this is a
humanitarian crisis I I talked to the
people who are coming over
they've been exploited extorted beaten
what's what's happened is the the all
things run by the Mexican drug cartel we
saw the buses the AF white buses the
cartelons
55 people of us they picked them up in
Mexicali and they bring them to the
border and they let them out the people
who come out are from every country
they're not you know they're from all
over and they have to pay the cartel
from Asia right they have to pay the
cartels to get through their land 50
well
right but they pay them usually up front
ten to fifteen thousand dollars to get
them across the United States and the
cartels are advertising all over the
world and they're advertising on YouTube
they're telling you exactly what's going
to happen to you
come across and then what happens is
they're given by the border patrol the
board there's nine border patrol
committed suicide because what they're
being asked to do is not their job
they're just
escorting people seven million people
have come across illegally in three
years and
legal immigration during that period was
3.1 million so the cartels are literally
controlling our immigration policy and
uh
we have a video that I made you know an
18 minute video that shows what happened
but but you were only down there for
what how long were you down there for I
was there for three days okay and then
um you know and then we've been dealing
you know we made the film we you know
I've been writing a lot about it and
researching it and it can totally be be
uh shut down overnight they're not and
what happens is people think what well
there you go there's a big all those
people are watching us but I just wonder
is that is that a long enough like time
to go see it like three days is that a
real life I had three intense days first
of all the first night watching all
these people come and then spending the
next days with local law enforcement
local sheriff's department the ice
the border patrol all the local medical
systems the doctors and doing you know
yeah interviews oh it's good to talk
with those people that's why we wanted
the guy because we kept hearing the
Border but it gets it gets like becomes
like this political like Red Rover that
that that different parties use and you
never know what's going on that's why we
wanted a border patrol agent and so we
could really see what happens there's a
guy called Chris clam who was the head
of the Border Patrol and Yuma
and he's fantastic and he's giving us
advice but you know what happens is a
lot of the Democrats think oh we're
being kind to these people by letting
them in but then we're not in fact
what happens is they're given a court
date for seven years in the future to go
to the Asylum court so they have seven
years in this country where there they
have no legal
status
so they're not allowed to work so they
um they they'll work for five percent
you know you have unscrupulous employers
yeah I'm five or six bucks an hour and
then you know they're they're employed
on construction sites in New York
the employee of the construction company
that's employing them is competing for
bids against a union labor company
because he's paying six bucks an hour
right so but just but just as guilty as
the as the people who are undermining
the system right as they are of
undermining the system people can have
their own like uh social beliefs about
it but there is guilt of undermining
what the system is that's in place but
those the people that pay them to work
are also guilty right if they're yeah I
mean when I you know what here's what I
would do
and first of all you need you need to
hire a thousand Asylum judges and you
need to adjudicate before people come in
once they come in they're entitled to
stay here they get a court date put them
right on the border like judge you
exactly and they adjudicate right there
and um and and then it will shut down
the border and but most of the people 99
of the people we interviewed didn't even
have an asylum claim they just said I'm
here to work I want a job right and so
they you know they are not entire they
have to come through the regular line
like everybody else legally yeah that's
what's fair is just doing it legally
because you can't keep if you don't have
Accounting in inventory of your business
then you're bound to go yeah you know
I'll tell you how you shut it down
overnight and this is what I'm going to
do the day I get into office
I'm going to wave passport fees for all
any American who can't afford it now
what that means is if you can get a
passport card I don't know if you've
seen it looks like a license right it's
a federal ID with your picture on it
and the problem is it costs 65 and
there's some paperwork attached that
makes it difficult for very poor people
to get them
and so there's a lot of people in our
country who are poor particularly in
cities who don't drive cars they don't
have a driver's license they have no
government issued ID now if you don't
have a government issued ID
you're a second class citizen you cannot
open a bank account which means you're
using you know the the uh paycheck uh
you know companies that take 10 of your
Social Security check they cash your
check
you can't get on an airplane you can't
stay at a hotel you can't visit your
kids at school and
um so what I'm going to do there's 33
000 post office in this country I'm
going to make it very easy for any
American citizen who can't afford it to
go down to the local post office and get
a passport ID
once they do that you now tell employers
you cannot hire somebody unless they
have that passport ID I will shut down
the Border overnight because nobody's
going to come through if they know they
cannot get a job because now you're
probably now you can prosecute employers
right now what they do the employer
instruction firm in New York they
they're just I don't care if you're
legal or illegal
they just want somebody who's cheapest
possible and that they can check the box
so they asked for social security card
the Social Security card has no picture
on it they're easily fabricated and
they're handed you know passed down from
person to person oh yeah those things
are nuts right and so you can't put the
employer in jail
because he says hey I I got a social
security card but now you're telling the
employer the employer is illegal for the
employer to do it right and now you're
saying you gotta have a passport card
where you're going to jail okay that at
that point
all illegal employment dries up
overnight nobody is going to employ
somebody with the risk of going to
prison
but and one other thing it'll do is that
um it will solve a lot of the anxieties
that people have Republicans
particularly about voting
because they say oh you know these
people are coming in and they're voting
people are voting without ID and they're
double voting they're committing voting
for well now everybody has an ID and you
can't have any of that kind of voting
fraud
and and the Democrats supported I mean
the Democrats will support it although
Biden won't sign this bill but um but
you know the big civil rights leaders
like Andy young Al Sharpton are all
behind this ID this idea so we can solve
all these problems and the anxieties and
debate about the voting system and
whether you need ID or not right now
Democrats oppose ID laws and the reason
they what they opposite is they say if
you get if you force people to show an
ID you're disenfranchising a lot of
students who don't have driver's license
you're disenfranchising poor people who
live in the city who don't have driver's
license
and there's other people in the country
elderly people a lot of their license
have left so they don't have ID and you
disenfranchise all of those those are
all Democrats so the Democrats say we
shouldn't ID laws
now we've got civil rights leaders who's
saying yeah let's have IDs to vote but
let's give everybody an ID so everybody
can get one right then nobody has an
excuse and nobody has an excuse yeah
what do you say to so some people would
say that that it that takes away some of
the old like adage and the old like uh
romantic idea of like
um you can come to America and you can
make it here does that does that do that
by making the Border because what are
you doing making the Border more
organized you're not saying there's no
country in the world that
has an insecure border yeah
we have to be able to control
we should let a lot of people in Legally
make it much easier to get citizenship
um and make sure that there's plenty of
people to you know to uh for employers
Etc
so that we can keep our country humming
yeah right and but we should be able to
select who comes through not have the
Mexican drug cartels select I agree